how is this for you it sucks
the ongoing traffic nightmare F1 circuit
Paving on the Strip impacting streets
far beyond now construction began two
months ago and this is expected to last
a whole lot longer thanks for joining us
at four I'm Brian Loftus I'm Kirsten
Joyce through it all F1 and Clark County
leaders have not answered specifics
about who's paying how much and what
this will all look like in the coming
years it looks like that you're not
moving eight news now reporter Ryan
Matthey live on the Strip at Flamingo
where crews are working on this repaving
process causing quite the Slowdown for
drivers Ryan
Brian it is obviously not moving and we
know this because we just spent about
half an hour trying to reach the
intersection down there you're not
successful of course this is all a scene
we've basically been seen for the past
two months and the question remains if
this is something drivers will just have
to endure each year
an internationally recognized sport it's
bad
leaving drivers wishing they turned
around by time consuming in the lights
you can't even tell which one is green
which one is not like right now Paving
through Friday is focused on Harmon
Avenue just off strip though some work
is still happening in front of Caesar's
Palace and the Bellagio
a mile drive took us 40 minutes amidst
cars from off strip trying to squeeze in
we anticipate a lifetime together that's
Clark County Commissioner jib Gibson
back in February when the board
unanimously voted F1 to be an annual
event potentially over the next decade
but who pays for it how much and will
this work be needed each year when I
reached out to F1 on Wednesday they
directed me back to this statement from
early April it said Commissioners are
considering the use of taxpayer dollars
to cover the cost a cost that neither F1
or Commissioners have confirmed initial
request they put in was for 37 million
dollars Las Vegas Convention and visitor
Authority President Steve Hill gave us
the only Insight back in March F1 asking
them for that 37 million which he says
is not even half of the total cost
and now we're left with this a county
commissioner's resolution that if passed
will enter Clark County into a
public-private partnership with F1
saying the race serves a public purpose
now that resolution argues that the race
is a public need since it provides
infrastructure safety because of that
infrastructure new jobs and economic
impacts to Clark County and it also says
the estimated cost of the circuit quote
reasonable reporting live on Flamingo
near the Strip by Matthew 8 news now
Ryan thank you this is what the County
spokesperson sent our Newsroom in
regards to Ryan's questions today they
say no dollar amount has been
established of how much money the county
could potentially put up if passed the
resolution allows them to begin
negotiating that amount